entraînement d'avant-match l'union tour
basket métropole né de la fusion de deux
clubs de la ville vient d'accéder à
l'antichambre des milieux professionnels
l'objectif est de l'intégrer au plus
vite le recrutement a été fait en
fonction parmi les nouveaux venus
le plus grand joueur évoluant en france
la senteur choc avec ses 2 mètres 22 son
quotidien pourrait paraître compliqué
aux yeux de certains il n'en est rien il
a toujours été grand il s'en accommode
tout simplement pour moi ça n'a jamais
été un handicap c'est juste une question
de de s'habituer à ce que à ce que la
vie me donne et puis et puis voilà mais
tant que ça m'empêche pas de rôle est de
trouver une voiture
faisait presque je faisais de mettre un
bus 13 ans j'ai toujours été au-dessus
pour moi c'était pas ça toujours été on
va dire une force est pas pas un
handicap comme comme le co2 personne
n'avait pensé matin et moi je m'amuse
avec voilà c'est ceci se passe si je
pourrais je sais pas comment expliquer
pour moi c'est une force et une
casquette c'est un choix une passion si
son parcours a parfois été chaotique
c'est que certains entraîneurs ne l'ont
pas intégré dans leur plan tactique lui
sait ce qu'il a à faire
fodé pouvoir gêner au maximum de prendre
les rebonds
après tout ce qui est en attaque voilà
moi je laisse le jeu venir à moi et puis
après match et un gars qui voit bien le
jeu donc c'est qu'en général je suis
mobilisé beaucoup de joueurs si je suis
pas bien bon jeu pour servir les ballons
et cole qui plaît tout bon après ce
combat je le prends et puis un dicton on
andré loire il a trouvé sa place il est
la tour de contrôle
[Applaudissements]
c'est un joueur dont qui est hors norme
on sait que il va pas courir très vite
on sait qu'en défense et des choses
qu'ils croient quoi faire donc il faut
vraiment s'adapter et on est en
construction donc c'est vrai que pour
l'instant on peut avoir des problèmes
ont peur des pertes de balle mais c'est
pas grave
sur ce match 15 points 11 rebonds nelly
nouveau ça met du temps il faut un bon
deux trois mois pour que tout le monde
arrive à se connaître avec des
automatismes une équipe on est jeune on
est l'équipe de bosseur donc je sais ce
qu'il vaut
vincent pourchot a élu domicile en
touraine pour deux ans le public est
déjà séduit